dea
I'm going to give a lesson in Japanese from now on.
So-called abbreviations are used everyday in Japan.
For example, high school girls are called jk, and people who can't read the air are called koi.
I heard that the frequency of use of this abbreviation is increasing.
Personally,
I don't like this abbreviation, but I can't deny that it is part of Japanese, so I
would like to introduce some abbreviations today.  To be
more specific, an abbreviation that seems to be possible in Japan in the future. The
number of people in the second half of the ojt Olympic traffic congestion is steadily increasing, expecting that the preparation for the Tokyo Olympics and the unprecedented congestion will occur among tourists.  Expecting
that a group of half and half will be clearly formed than Japanese,
sgh mgh Half Mac with sushi Monthly
No. 3 I expect that a pure foreigner who was born and raised in Japan, not half someday, will be Miss Japan.
mis The 4th winner is a Brazilian,
so I expect a carnival boom.
Mosberger No. 6 As it is, the idol boom continues to expand, but
I expect that an idol group will be formed even in the countryside.
4 t 8 h s 4 d 7 td
fk 4 t 7 against Forty Eight 4 t 7 prefectures
8th  I think
it's okay to omit this because I'm omitting other words enough for 1 type 5 h 1 kitchen file 1 expecting that the tax will rise further in the old car and the number of people who can not save money will increase
.  People will come out
and kfc Kenta Kentucky
No. 11 Seeing foreign companies adopt the latest technology more and more, expecting that many people will notice the hardness of their company's head
mgk Useless business meeting No. 12 latest  Expecting that the week when Japanese companies will fall after seeing the foreign-affiliated companies that have put too much technology in turmoil and crushing
will be
overwhelmed
by fax 13 from in my f mail  It is not necessary to use abbreviations, and
it is easier to understand if you separate the pure national language.